let's hear from a few more people in the
audience after all the show is for
people in the audience it's not for me
to sit in a room by myself with a
microphone as fun as that could be we
take calls via discord davidpakman.com
slash discord okay very very important
slash discord
why don't we speak next to harry from
columbus ohio welcome harry
david obviously can you hear me yes i
can
thanks for taking my call
um
sorry i need to drag my memory
real quickly also your audio is
atrocious it's like blinking in and out
it's like a popcorn connection
is it really really about give me one
second to try to address it all right
any better for you david you know it's
not but i think i'll i'll be able to
hear your question if you remember it
yeah i do um so i have a question about
uh dinesh de souza
last time first thing i'd heard about it
was that he was
somebody who denied the the southern
strategy that was what i had
known him for can you tell me a little
bit more about him like in regards to
like you know
2000 mules even trump mentioned it
recently what do you know about dinesh
well i know he's a convicted felon um
and a grifter uh no the film we've
talked about the film 2000 mules 2000
mules is a film by dinesh d'souza which
makes the argument that on the basis of
mobile phone geo location data that's
quite frankly not very accurate it makes
the argument that there were two
thousand so-called mules or ballot
traffickers
who were making massive dumps of
fraudulent ballots into ballot drop
boxes or as trump likes to call them
drock boxes
and um it's all completely
unsubstantiated and uh it's i wouldn't
spend too much time honestly thinking
about dinesh d'souza
okay i have then real quickly more
substantially do you think um it will
be you know successful for
somebody like uh to get into ohio
politics for
uh tim ryan he seems to be trying to tap
to the middle
really hard he has an ad that says uh
you know
democrats really messed it up shipping
jobs to china but you know i'm
pro-union i'm you know pro
socially
uh do you think that can work to win
over but you know suburban ohio
i think it might yeah i think it might i
mean i think i don't know enough about
the ohio electorate but i think it's
completely plausible and i support ryan
and i hope he does crush in november
yeah i just don't know how powerful the
anti-china message is for deaf
democrats that's a fair question don't
buy it yeah
we'll have to wait and see what the
result is
all right i'm gonna let you that the
connection is just ungodly so we will um
we're gonna let you go but i appreciate
all of the questions there a lot of
important stuff as many of you know i'm
a busy person i don't always have the
exact correct nutritional plan for my
meals every single day and that's why i
also take a multivitamin and a couple of
supplements but doing them all
separately can be a little bit time
consuming which is why athletic greens
is just fantastic and they're one of our
sponsors i've been using the athletic
greens since last year it just really
simplifies nutrition i just do a scoop
of the ag-1 and i'm getting 75 high
quality vitamins and minerals and my
probiotics and it's all from whole food
sources i drink it in the morning i know
i'm good i don't have to be messing
around with different pills and
supplements or whatever or spend time
planning when what time of day do i need
to take each one i just get it all with
one scoop you can put it in a smoothie
you can drink it straight it tastes
great and then i'm just good for the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below